[Music]
don's in seattle
hey don how are you better than i
deserve dave how are you
better than we deserve how can we help
ah well
so i am very new to being a business
owner
i'm oh six or seven months in i have an
insurance agency
and i have one employee and i am
struggling
with knowing when to be
compassionate and when to be firm when
it comes to
my employees viewpoints slash behaviors
and and then the other thing is there a
point where
the drama they bring outweighs
the profit they produce i think you're
already there
[Laughter]
i could be wrong but i can smell this oh
it's so painful though you have
one employee yes sir
are they killing it financially and
driving you crazy
well the first month um
yes the second month not so much we are
now going into
month three of it and i've been i've had
my agency open for
um six months now
okay and the employee is supposed to be
doing what selling
insurance yes um selling insurance
through you know internet leads
and how old is this person 27
oh 27 year olds know everything yeah so
um when i was in your seat
i love your question because it shows a
big heart
and also a strong backbone both
the way you phrased it um and you're
trying you you know you have the power
to just move this person on and yet
uh you want to do what's right by them
and be
wise and learn how to lead and these are
all the way you phrase the question is
very strong
very powerful so um when i was in your
seat
i uh with the first several team members
particularly in the south this is a
particular southern disease
but it's everywhere but it's really bad
in the south we have this thing where
in the name of being nice we will
tolerate crap for
years and i was trying to be
nice to people and what i figured out
was i was getting progressively
frustrated
all the way into anger and i if i didn't
watch it was going to just boil over
suddenly rather than me controlling the
environment
and so that's when i coined the phrase
for myself
to be unclear is to be unkind
because if you don't bring if you don't
let people in on what's going on inside
your head
then how can you expect them to have a
chance to adjust it's all in your head
and in the name of being nice you're not
telling them the truth
about what's driving you bananas now you
don't have to be blunt or angry or
rude to them but you owe them a
difficult conversation
john which often means you owe yourself
a difficult conversation of why is this
driving me crazy what are the actual
like so i i'm interested what are the
viewpoints that
your teammate uh is talking about that's
driving you bananas
well i'm i'm 48 myself and i see the
world
through the eyes of a 48 year old um and
they were 27 and i try to remember
what it was like when i was 27
and they are more mature than i was
at that age and i've also seen the
growth
that they've had since i met them six
months ago
give me an example um what are you
talking about like
is it politics or is it is it religion
like what is what is it
well some of it's politics religion
really
isn't it but just more of like
behavioral viewpoints how
i see the world um for instance
i am not a victim i create my own
destiny
and i'm gonna do it so let me help you
with this that's not an age thing that's
a world viewpoint thing i got a building
full of 27 year olds
that are not victims and they believe
they create the world the other ones i
don't hire them
because i don't want to work with
victims or people that think that
everybody's a victim
and the systemic man is out to get them
i got
i got crap to do and those people don't
do anything they whine
and i don't have time for them i love
the millennial generation
because there are only two kinds awesome
and sucks
and i hire the awesome ones i got a we
got a bunch of them yeah we have some
unbelievable young people in this
building
and none of them are playing the victim
fiddle
none of them are thinking that society
is out to get them none of them think
that socialism is better than capitalism
and so i think you've got a bad hire
well that is the decision i've been
struggling with yeah you you you hired a
cat and you're trying to train it to be
a dog
have you sat down and said here are the
four things that need to change
i have not okay um this person has a
value system that does not align with
the owner of the company
if you your value systems have to be
aligned for you to have unity
you don't have to be in complete
agreement john and i have some fun
disagreements we argue
and fuss and fight and uh he thinks i'm
sometimes crazy and sometimes i think
he's way overeducated i mean we have
some great
discussions we love each other and trust
each other but
overall our values underneath all of
those arguments
are the exact same or very very close to
the same
and that enables us to have these
discussions and disagreements that's
where
the values have to line up the beliefs
can be all over the place that's why you
read new books to change your beliefs to
learn new things
but your values he's reading a book
right now that's bizarre that i
recommended to him and i just finished
one that's bizarre that he recommended
to me
yeah and that's what friends do and i'm
hoping to change my beliefs on something
right
but my values are the same our values
are very very similar and we
actually both came to the same
conclusions about these books
the good parts and the bad parts that
where the author was off and on and that
kind of thing so i
i i think you're probably going to part
ways but you can try so have a clear
conversation and say
here this is what's driving me crazy and
honestly
i don't think the listen i don't know
how you're going to produce in a
capitalistic straight commission
environment selling insurance when you
think you're a victim or you think other
people are victims they're not victims
we need now is there situations where
people are oppressed you bet
are there situations where people don't
have the same starting line absolutely
are there all kinds of isms out there
that are real abso dad gum lutely
there's isms everywhere
there's jerks and ignorant people around
every corner does that mean you can't
win
absolutely not right you can still win
and so if you sit down and have that
hard conversation and say here's who
we're going to be moving forward
and i'm not we're not going to do it
otherwise and i love you and then your
employees got a decision to make yeah
and it's okay
i'll still love you if you don't work
here yeah that's something you do great
dave
i love you you know you cannot work here
and still go to heaven yeah
it you know it's not required yeah it's
you can work a lot of places and still
go to heaven
you'll not it's not a cult you'll see
some kind of it is you'll see i'm just
kidding
not funny you'll you'll see somebody in
the grocery store that used to work here
and you'll still give them a hug right
yeah absolutely yeah
in a dead run yeah you know i mean
really yeah because i just
there's so many people i mean it's we
got a thousand here and in 30 years
there's a thousand about that don't work
here right
you know and uh my wife and i joke about
we would never work with each other
right like in a business
that doesn't mean we don't love it just
does it means
there's too much going on and here's the
thing everything moves at the speed of
trust and when you can't trust
someone's foundational underpinnings
that means you don't know what they're
going to do right you don't have a
predictable environment and business is
all about creating is a predictable
environment
and that's with your team members team
members like the predictable environment
because the
leader is steady and you know i don't
always agree with him but i know exactly
what he's going to do i don't always
agree with her but i know exactly how
they think about this
they love that that's called integrity
and i also want
when i was a leader i always wanted to
surround myself with people who saw the
world differently than me
values but i don't want someone to say
oh you vote that way or you think this
so you're out of here
go back to the what are your values be
clear you can spell trump so i can't
associate
with you whatever it is yeah man
surround yourself by people who think
differently but who have
the same values that's it yeah i don't
think this one's going to make it but
you can give it a run
yeah but it's going to be good for you
in the process clear conversations
check out the entree leadership website
there's some good stuff on there about
it the podcast is really good